we've been reporting all morning long on
the landmark decision by the Supreme
Court striking down affirmative action
in college admissions the six to three
ruling said race cannot be a factor in
admissions the U.S Department of
Education says it will study this ruling
and send more guidance to schools in the
next 45 days we are joined Now by
Secretary of Education that's Miguel
Cardona to discuss good morning
secretary it's very good to see you and
very good to have you on this particular
day so I know you've been looking thank
you very much to be with you we're glad
that you're here what does this decision
mean on a practical basis realistically
for college admissions going forward we
know what it says what does it mean to
you
you know it's it's really disappointing
we're not at the point in this country
we're living up to our ideals to make
higher education accessible to everyone
so what this does is remove a tool that
has been used to help move our
universities toward that goal of
providing access to all students across
the country it removes race as a factor
that could be considered in admissions
is what it does
Mr secretary why are you and the
administration so committed to this
particular tool to address inequality
given that it doesn't pull all that well
at best public opinion even among those
likely to benefit is lukewarm and there
are nine states ranging from California
down to Florida who say who've already
banned affirmative action so given that
state of public opinion and public
thought why is the administration so
committed to this tool in particular
you know I think if the framing of the
polling matters you know when you ask
people
is it important to make sure that all
students have access to higher education
they would say yes is it important to
make sure that we address inequities
that exist in our K-12 system where
place and race are still sadly
predictors of ability to access higher
education and when you talk about
California look in 1996 they shot down
affirmative action right there was a
decrease of about 50 percent of black
and Latino students in some of their top
tier schools now they've tried to
recover but they haven't fully recovered
from that so there are less black and
brown students in higher education in
those schools as a result of that
decision in this country with a growing
number of Latinos in particular we need
to make sure that we're providing access
to higher education for black and brown
students to to be honest about the fact
that even with affirmative action the
numbers are Stark and that there are
gaps in higher education achievement
but Mr secretary the voters seemed to be
saying to you to to their leaders uh
across the country elected and otherwise
that they want this push for equality to
start earlier and that's kind of on you
as a secretary of education can't you
fix this problem before it gets to
college admissions
yeah you know that's a really good point
and and let's not ignore the fact that
look at where we are even before the
pandemic we we know that achievement
disparities exist we know that Health
disparities exist access to mental
health disparities exist we are focused
at the Department of Education we have a
strategy called raise the bar lead the
world you can see it on ed.gov where we
are focusing on literacy and numeracy
because it's abysmal the fact that the
students across the country are not at
the level they need to be so we are
focusing on that but that does not uh
give us the ability to ignore the fact
that we are not providing equal access
in higher education and that that's a
responsibility for all of us and that
diverse student bodies in higher
education make the learning better for
all students
Mr secretary Nate hears the Supreme
Court decision will not apply to
military academies what message does
that send to minorities
yeah exactly I mean it it doesn't apply
there but it applies everywhere else
it's unfortunate I think what we need to
do is collectively uh reflect on the
benefit of having a diverse student body
one that reflects the diversity in our
country that should be Universal
throughout our entire country at the
Department of Education we're taking
this very seriously we're going to focus
on uh within 45 days providing guidance
to college presidents saying what the
law of what the Supreme Court decision
says and what it doesn't say the ruling
is was based on you can't make a
decision based on race but nothing was
done about Legacy students you know
there are so many students who are
getting into schools that some would
argue are not qualified just because
your family's name is on the building
your family has donated a lot of money
some could call that also discrimination
in Reverse what do you say about that
absolutely absolutely there are several
other things that are not uh targeted by
by this decision it was only race it
doesn't you know Legacy as you mentioned
wealth uh that that's also some a factor
if someone can just write a check and
pay the tuition that's that's a factor
that's being used uh to allow for
admission and again it speaks to
um the challenge that we're going to
have in this country when the Supreme
Court is making a decision that takes
away this tool from higher education
institutions thank you very much
secretary Cardona for joining us we
really appreciate it